[Musique]
j'aimerais vous amener aujourd'hui dans
un talk j'aimerais que vous puissiez
garder votre scepticisme j'aimerais que
vous puissiez ressentir en vous
l'impact que vous pourriez avoir le jour
vous serez authentique et on va parler
d'authenticité mais on va parler de
cette urgence à l'être à être
authentique pour créer votre propre
réalité donc ce soir on parle de sortir
du cadre mais en fait le cadre c'est
vous qui le créez ouais ouais alors
j'entends déjà il y en a qui disent
ouais non c'est quand même un peu le
gouvernement et d'autres qui
disent non mais c'est lui non
c'est le moment d'arrêter de pointer du
doigt parce que c'est nous qui créons
notre cadre comment par notre attitude
par nos pensées par notre vibration
d'accord donc je vais vous raconter un
petit peu ma vie
toute petite
j'ai regardé l'humain
j'observais l'humain avec amour un amour
qu'on peut pas définir mais qui doit se
ressentir et je les voyais comme ça
magnifique dans leur lumière dans leur
rôle et puis tout à coup je me dis mais
il a mis un masque mais pourquoi tu mets
un masque et l'autre tu me dis mais
pourquoi il met un rôle bon ok bon
j'étais un enfant j'avais pas encore
compris j'avais pas encore compris mais
comme vous tous et toutes
j'ai grandi
et alors
j'observais toujours mais j'étais un peu
embrumée parce que je me disais d'accord
j'observe un truc sur l'humain que je
savais pas vraiment d'où ça venait mais
on me le confirmait jamais en fait on me
disait bah non c'est pas ce que tu vois
alors j'ai cru que je commençais à
devenir un imposteur on a tous touché
déjà ce syndrome de l'imposteur pire une
menteuse pourtant des mentors j'en ai
rencontré quand j'étais inspectrice à la
police de sûreté que tant de Vaud vous
savez vers Lausanne très très loin là en
Suisse mais là je pouvais comprendre je
me disais ok le menteur il est là c'est
sûr que lui il a un truc à défendre donc
même si je lisais un désalignement entre
sa gestuelle et son audio je me dis ok
c'est normal il m'a un masque là il y a
de la survie quoi un jeu ça je pouvais
comprendre et puis je suis devenu coach
parce que j'adore l'humain depuis
toujours alors j'ai dit bon ces humains
elle va les aider à être authentique et
alors là j'ai eu un choc j'ai vraiment
eu un choc parce que j'ai des gens qui
venaient me chercher pour les aider à
atteindre leur potentiel et vous savez
quoi
et ben vous mettiez aussi des masques
alors là je me suis dit je comprends
plus rien à l'histoire de tonicité
police je peux imaginer petite fille
peut-être que je me trompais il fallait
que je me mette face à cette
authenticité mais alors dans une
expérience un peu béton donc j'ai décidé
de faire
elle a dit tout à l'heure c'est trop
facile Koh-Lanta d'accord Koh-Lanta pour
ceux qui connaissent pas c'est un jeu de
survie hein hop on vous envoie sur une
île aux a rien à bouffer il faut vous
débrouiller puis il faut se battre les
uns contre les autres ok alors moi je
suis arrivé dans le jeu en me disant ok
j'adore l'humain je vais être pure
bienveillante intègre et je vais gagner
ce jeu sans aucune stratégie on n'a pas
besoin de stratégie
même pas un rêve parce que les filles
assez vite comme ça elles m'ont sorti du
jeu après 20 jours pourtant pourtant moi
j'avais la capacité à analyser ce qui se
passait donc on a essayé de me faire
passer pour une super coach mais j'ai
pas étalé l'analyse de la crédibilité
pour voir que les autres mettaient en
place une stratégie mais pourquoi
j'avais la médaille de l'honneur j'étais
sorti pure intègre authentique de ce jeu
là
alors la stratégie vous êtes comme moi
parfois il en faut par contre je vous
avertis d'une chose ne restez pas dans
l'illusion que quand vous êtes stratège
vous êtes authentique mais j'avais donc
cette question je me suis dit ok est-ce
qu'on a besoin d'être pur pour être
authentique
je vous la laisse
du coup je me suis dit j'observe quelque
chose
c'était le moment de prendre les choses
en main
il fallait que ma quête commence
donc je l'ai commencé
et j'ai été chercher les plus grands
experts en analyse comportementale et
j'ai reçu le vrai badge du FBA par Joey
Navarro donc j'ai été chercher les deux
plus grands spécialistes du FBI Paul
Ekman vous connaissez policeman like to
me
in
outman
c'est le micro-expression 8 ans de
recherche
quand vous êtes face à une groupe face à
une salle si vous osez vous dire donc
que vous êtes dans votre potentiel vous
allez être détendu congruant si vous
commencez à ne pas oser vous dire ou ne
pas vouloir vous dire il va y arriver
sur votre visage un micro mouvement oui
et ça pour moi c'est une fenêtre de
opportunité je me dis la personne en
face de moi ne peut pas se dire et
c'était génial je me suis dit mais voilà
ce que je lis depuis tout petit ça
c'était une coche de fête je savais lire
les micro expressions comme vous savez
tous les lire puisque nous naissons fait
pour lire l'autre au-delà des mots on ne
peut pas ne pas communiquer vous le
savez et puis ok c'était sympa mais il
fallait que je comprenne autre chose
donc j'ai fait un peu de neurosciences
et j'ai dit comment fonctionne ce
cerveau j'ai appris une chose
phénoménale qui donne de nouveau
confirmer mon intuition c'est que notre
cerveau il a plusieurs niveaux de centre
de décision il y en a un qui s'appelle
l'animal reptile olympique que vous avez
pas envie d'être ici votre pied va se
barrer
au cas où personne regardait je pourrais
partir d'accord c'est des signaux qu'on
appelle authentiques parce que vous
pouvez pas réagir contre mais qui sont
en train de vous dire je suis dans
l'animal en moi j'ai peur j'ai
authentique mon peur et alors ça
confirmait un truc que j'avais toujours
réfléchi pourquoi j'étais coach dans les
années 2000 on m'avait dit il faut faire
sortir les gens de la zone de confort
je trouvais ça un peu bizarre mais tout
le monde le disait donc moi j'ai
appliqué sans aucun résultat elle a tout
à coup j'avais un éclairage je me disais
alors l'humain
si il a un inconfort il est dans
l'animal est-ce que c'est l'animal de
l'humain que je veux rencontrer et je
vous pose la question à vous tous dans
cette salle qui manager des équipes qui
gèrent et des gens même si c'est une
famille pour toutes les femmes qui sont
dans la maison est-ce que ça vaut la
peine de mettre l'humain en face de vous
en inconfort vous avez détecté quoi sa
stratégie de survie est-ce qu'on
communication interpersonnelle c'est
important de savoir que je vais plutôt
me bagarrer que de fuir non par contre
si vous êtes à même de me mettre en
confort
vous allez avoir accès à une autre
partie de mon cerveau qui s'appelle le
lobe préfrontal et celui-là il est trop
piscine parce que c'est le distributeur
le novateur c'est le super cerveau et
vous donne quoi comme signe de comme
signe à lire du confort donc si vous
avez qu'une seule responsabilité en tant
qu'humain c'est de lire les signes de
confort chez votre interlocuteur comme
ça vous avez la certitude que vous avez
accès à son potentiel c'était une
découverte magnifique donc je vous
propose la première fois la prochaine
fois que vous allez faire la gestion
d'équipe vous voyez même de famille je
vous ai dit si vous mettez la pression
vous avez accès à qui
vous avez accès à qui à l'animal vous
voulez pas l'animal donc vous allez
commencer à être congruant je dis
quelque chose je fais une geste qui
accompagne ce que je dis je suis ravie
d'être aujourd'hui ici je suis congruant
donc je ne crée pas chez mon
interlocuteur une zone d'inconfort et
alors en face de vous vous avez un
humain qui dit je suis je suis capable
d'être qui je suis et là vous aurez vous
aurez gagné il y a beaucoup de zèbre
d'accord et alors c'est magnifique de
comprendre ça et d'essayer de
l'appliquer chez vous mais il me restait
une question parce que vous savez qu'on
ne voit la réalité que selon notre
propre monde et pourquoi est-ce que vous
savez pourquoi on ne voit la réalité
qu'à travers notre propre monde parce
que notre cerveau dans les 1 milliard
d'informations qui reçoit la seconde il
va trier lesquels
celle qui nous met en confort et je vous
le confirme encore qui c'est qui a déjà
pris la parole en public il y en a qui
s'est bien fermé d'autres personnes dans
la salle d'accord vous faites quoi quand
vous arrivez sur ça votre bouche et elle
est comment
elle est comment votre bouche
sèche votre corps est fait quoi
pour vous calmer vous faites ce qu'on
appelle un geste pacificateur vous
touchez la main vous buvez de l'eau
d'accord donc c'est magnifique de vous
rendre compte à quel point votre corps
sa seule responsabilité c'est de garder
l'homéostasie pour avoir accès à son
plein potentiel donc moi j'ai trouvé ça
génial et je me suis dit ok si je ne
sais pas la réalité de l'autre comment
je vais faire pour la découvrir puisque
je sais bien cognitif qui m'empêche de
voir l'arrêter telle qu'elle est vous
connaissez tout le biais de confirmation
là vous achetez un nouveau natel vous
n'aviez pas besoin
mais dès que vous arrivez à la maison
vous avez mille raisons de savoir que
vous avez besoin vous voyez ce que je
veux dire mais vous rendez compte que
quand vous faites un recrutement par
exemple c'est la même chose si vous
n'aimez pas le gars en face de vous
votre bide confirmation ne fait pareil
il trie qu'est-ce qu'il aime pas
la vérité désolé j'ai formé beaucoup de
gens je peux vous confirmer donc je me
suis dit il faut que je développe une
technique et quand vous avez compris que
le cerveau conditionné l'animal il
n'aime pas être agressé il va se
défendre donc si vous posez une question
à quelqu'un faites attention vous
réveiller l'animal le cerveau
conditionné donc je me suis dit je vais
arrêter de poser des questions aux gens
je vais leur raconter des histoires
storytelling je vais créer des émotions
dans leur corps vous allez me dire c'est
un peu bizarre votre truc alors je vous
donne un exemple pour que vous
compreniez Carole dans la salle une amie
très chère pas tout à fait vrai parce
que je veux dire mais elle vient vers
moi un jour elle me dit tu sais Caro moi
j'ai de l'angoisse à prendre la parole
en public est-ce que tu pourrais
m'accompagner on le fait quelques temps
puis elle revient de trois semaines
après elle me dit ah Caro mais non c'est
super j'ai plus de problème à prendre la
parole en public
what non parce que j'ai une micro
expression de peur dans la gorge j'ai un
nom de la tête alors qu'elle dit oui
c'est une fenêtre d'opportunité sur
laquelle je dois revenir pour être sûr
que c'est ce qu'elle est en train de
ressentir si je pose une question vous
imaginez bien que son cerveau risque de
se défendre mais si je lui raconte tu
sais quoi Carole Didier lui alors il
kiffe alors plus il y a de monde dans la
salle alors plus il kiffe que les gens
l'observent et tout et c'est à ce
moment-là je vois de nouveau dans ses
yeux de la peur je confirme dans son
corps qui lui est toujours authentique
qu'elle n'a pas encore dépassé son
angoisse j'imaginais c'est génial quand
même l'analyse de la congruence donc
j'ai décidé d'aller former un peu les
gens je me suis dit bon allez FBI on va
former des gens et j'ai formé plus que
800 personnes je crois à 700 je sais
plus en Suisse à cette technique et
arriver à mon regard un truc qui
s'appelle l'intelligence artificielle
pour ceux qui connaissent et je me suis
dit mais alors je tiens un outil qui me
permettrait d'être cette troisième
personne un troisième regard sans biais
cognitif donc on a créé une intelligence
artificielle qui est à même de lire tous
les signaux que vous émettez mais de
manière transparente elle voulait
remonte sur une vidéo et sur une
timeline sur laquelle vous pouvez
constater ce qui se passe pour vous donc
si on utilisateur il peut revenir avec
vous sur ces fenêtres d'opportunité pour
confirmer ce qui s'est passé pour vous
vous pouvez apprendre à de vous-même
surtout si vous êtes filmé dans un détox
mais vous pouvez aussi apprendre en tant
que candidat ce qui s'est passé
et là je me suis dit waouh c'est quand
même génial
à 52 ans on va pas dire j'étais une
jeune start-up on peut le dire mais en
tout cas startup et je me suis dit cette
quête de recherche d'authenticité cette
question que vous posez tout à l'heure
est-ce qu'il faut être pur pour être
authentique Balma amené à faire quoi
être formé par les meilleurs
instructeurs du FBI ça c'était cool à
confirmer mon observation de l'enfant
que j'étais petite de me dire je vois
quelque chose et puis elle m'a même
amené à créer une intelligence
artificielle puis faire le tour du monde
tu aurais hello
c'était cool quoi mais j'avais toujours
cette question de se dire est-ce qu'on
doit être authentique pure bienveillant
et vraiment je l'ai cru longtemps
j'ai tellement cru que je suis devenu
une authentique et j'avais pas le cadre
que je voulais
vraiment j'avais pas le cas que je
voulais parce que comme dans Koh-Lanta
je me faisais toujours passer après les
autres comme dans Koh-Lanta j'utilisais
pas ce que les gens disent un talent
parce que je me disais qui suis-je pour
vous voyez j'étais pas authentique mais
la vie m'a envoyé une leçon la trahison
ça provoque quoi pour vous la trahison
comme émotion la colère généralement non
bah non moi c'était la culpabilité
encore une fois valait mieux que je
crève tout de suite c'était toujours
j'avais fait quelque chose de fou et
tout là j'ai dû manger un peu plus ça
suffit stop stop je veux être
authentique je ne veux plus me
culpabiliser et audatours d'un travail
personnel justement j'ai décidé de créer
mon cadre et mon cadre ça a été cette
décision là
j'ai dit depuis aujourd'hui
je décide à chaque instant d'être aligné
entre cette vibration cette être peu
importe comme vous l'appelez ce corps de
matière qui communique par la voix et
par la gestuelle
peu importe les lunettes que je porte
Vincent peu importe le regard que les
autres ont sur vous ou sur nous ou sur
toi peu importe votre conditionnement
peu importe vos peurs je suis
je suis qui je suis et j'ai accepté qu'à
l'intérieur de moi siège le meilleur
comme le pire et j'aimerais juste que
vous touchiez
l'authenticité qui est la vôtre parce
que quand vous aurez fait cette décision
depuis votre cœur de devenir quelqu'un
d'authentique de congruant vous allez
créer votre propre cadre et je certaines
que vous réussirez parce que les humains
font tellement plus que ce qu'ils
croient et qui sont capables de faire et
pour terminer j'aimerais juste que vous
écoutiez cette musique ces cinq secondes
que vous retenez le goût de ce que c'est
d'être authentique
[Musique]
c'est bon
et alors grâce à cette note de musique
qui est la vôtre vous écrirez votre
partition merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]